サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
えっと 今日は  毎月恒例の
えっと ね なんて言いますか
講演ありましたので まあ今年今回はそれもできなくなったので
その代わりに今日は何か
テーマを一つ組み立てて
講演の代わりに話してみたいと思います
今日はテーマといったっても
このいわゆる何でしたっけ？この宗教の世界でよくこの
ものすごいたくさん物語があるんですね
それからこの神話的な話
神秘的な話 すごいたくさんあるんですよ
それで これって何なのかと考えることになったんです
そうなった理由は あの
あの 英語ではこのイエス様と聖書に対して結構研究が進んでいて
ものすごい膨大な研究がありましてね
そこでこの研究の結論として
このあれですね  イエスというのは
この本当に全くも歴史的な人物ではありませんと
で だから作ったキャラであると
膨大な証拠を出すんですね
それでキリスト教の方々もね
やっぱりどうせ反論しますからね
イエス様は本当に歴史的にユダヤ
イスラエルに生活した人だとずっと話したりする
しかし 客観的にどう見ても
イエス様が実際いた人物であるという証拠は全く出てこない
そこで このイエス様がいたとされる時期で
シリアからね あのとイスラエルにね
旅に出た人々の記録がありまして
イスラエルに起きてる
まあ単純なつまらないものまで旅の記録として書いてますけど
イエスに対しては一言葉も書いてないんですね
だからイエス様っていうのは最変な方で
もうユダヤ教のテンプルをね
繰り返したりして まあ奇跡を次から次へと起こして
目が見えない人に目が見えるようにするわとかね
歩けない人を歩かせるわとかね
それでたくさん人々を集めて説法していたって
ひとかけらもその人のことを聞いたことがないっていうのはね
でおかしいと  それだけでもなく
またあの この新約聖書に書いてる４つのテキストをね
特にイエスのキャラクターを書いているね
全部この 150年 イエス様がいたとされる時期から 100年
150年の間で書かれただろうという話で
だからアイウィットネスとして書くんだけど
直弟子たちが書いたと
直弟子たちは全然書いてないんですね
だから直弟子たちも本当はいてなかったんですね
直弟子ですか  直弟子 それからずっと私は読んでみたら
このイエスのキャラクターの一つ一つ場面を出してね
いかにこれ変かおかしいかというところね
あの学者は学問的に分析しているんですね
ですから 結論は このキリスト教という宗教を作るために
膨大莫大な神話物語が必要であったということなんですね
ふっ 特にあのイエス様がこの十字架で殺されるんですね
そんなことは全く起きてない
だから３日経ってから蘇ることもありえない
で あったならば この４人そこを記録書いているんだから
同じものでなければありませんだけど ４
種類ですね で ユダスに対しても
ユダスどうなったのかと
なんでユダスがいたのかと
ユダスという弟子一人がいるんだけど
最後にあの 金の貨幣のね
20個をもらうためにイエス様を売り売ってしまったと
それはおかしい なぜならば
イエス様が派手に宣伝していたんだからね
だからイエス様のことをこの人
イエス様と言うために
あの知らなかった人ではないんです
聖書にとって よく知られている人ですからね
誰かにイエスをこの人と確認してくださいという必要もないし
それからこのまあほとんど嘘ばっかりで
最近がなんていうます
ユダヤ人 ユダヤ文化の詳しい偉い人がね
あのまあ法律家でね あの
この裁判を起こしたことは
もう随分ギリシア人が勘違いしているんだと
これはユダヤ法律ではないんだと
全くもう一 あの このサバサマーの例なんですね
それはお祭りの宗教をお祭りの日は絶対そういうことをやらないのは決まりだと
だから一般の日でなくちゃいけない
それから裁判とか あの
まだユダヤ人の間でこういうあの死刑を決めるような裁判は行わなかったと
それからこのテンペルの偉いお坊さんがね
あの そういう裁判をやる場合は
テンプル このユダヤ教会の違うところで
個人の家では絶対やってはいけないという
もう全部このユダヤの文化によってありえない裁判の場面を書いているんですね
ということは 書いた人はそれほどユダヤ人の文化のことは知らなかったということで
ただ物語を書いただけなんですね
だからまあそれでそんな話はどうでもいいんだけど
そういう方々はギリシアでこのユダヤ的なユダヤ人の宗教を一般人にも教えたかったんですね
結局は だからユダヤ教を教えられませんね
極限に入った あの入った的だからね
だからまあもっとユダヤ人の考え
ちょこちょこと取り受け取って
いろんな哲学者の考えをまとめて
一つのキリスト教という宗教を作ったんですね
だから旧約聖書からまたいろいろな
預言者からね あの話はパクったんだから
やっぱりキリストユダヤ教的にならなくちゃいけないね
だから 人の罪を赦すためには
イエスというキャラを作って
それは神の子でありとかね
その中でも異論 2つありまして
生まれる前から罪のない神であったという話もあって
イエスは人間で生まれて
あの洗礼を受けた時点で
あのもう肉体が清らかになって
それから神が自分の息子として昇格しましたっていう
だから本当のそれにしてたっても
あまりアイデアがまとめてないんですね
だからあのイエス様が受難したという
この神話物語に基づいて
人々に新しい宗教を教えていくんですね
だからそこで教えがそれなりにまとめてない中で
キリスト教の人々がいたんですね
だからキリスト教っていうのは
このメシアという救済者が出てくるんだというユダヤ人の信仰があってね
だからこのインチキの救済者というのがあちらこちらから出てくるんですね
それでギリシアでも一つ作ってみたっていうことなんですね
実際 私はメシアという人々はいたんだけどね
みんなほとんど病気な人々でね
まあそういうふうな この当時であったいろんなもの
情報を集めて 新しいストーリーを作って
それは同じこと イスラム教でもあるしね
完璧にあの神話物語で成り立っているんですね
モハメドっていう預言者がいたかどうか結局わからないんですね
それで全部 あの 何といいますか
神話的な物語で組み立ててはいるんですね
で そこはまあよく 考えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんですね
私も それでまあ日本の仏教とか何とか見てみたら
ものすごいもういろんなもう神話物語
派手にたくさんあるんですね
まあ実際はこのお釈迦
仏教はお釈迦様という人物が教えた教えというふうに一般的に言われてあって
かなり古い時代の人だからね
現代知識人が明確に設定するような情報は薄いかもしれませんだけど
ブッダもそんなキャラはいなかったんだよという学者もいるんですね
この作ったキャラですよと
しかし あんまりそこは人気ないですね
ブッダが作ったキャラクターだよということはね
やっぱりブッダという人物がいたっていうことは
一般的な仏教以外の人々の考えでもありますね
そこで今日考えるべきポイントは
まああまり厳しく言うので軽く言いますけどね
なんでこんなに宗教にこの神話物語が絡んでいるのかと
で ただ我々普通の人間で自分のことを考えてみると
で 私も他の人々も誰だって子供頃
神話物語が好きなんですね
私もちっちゃい時覚えてますよ
すごい苦労して あのあのろくに英語も読めないのに
分厚い本がグリムスグリムスフェアリーテイルズというね
あの そういう神話物語
グリム兄弟のね ああ 苦労して苦労して読みましたからね
本当に当時でそんなに英語もできたわけでもないんです
だから あの 何て言いますかね
カエルも魔女が呪って王子様がカエルになるわ
子供たちが森に迷い込んだところで
魔女に あのケーキ スイーツでできた
お菓子の家  お菓子の家があってね
これもう食べてしまっちゃって
それでもう中でね あの魔女がいて
この子供はスープにしようかなと
で そんな風なこの面白くてしょうがないんですよ
もう だからこの心理学的に何か人間は神話物語が好きなんですね
で そこで何なのかって
これってよくわからない
そこで現代人も 大人もなかなか成長してないんです
で 一昨日から Netflix フリックスで
まあもうもうなんとか苦労して回分けて映画を本見たんです
タイトルはタイタンとなんとかなんですけどね
アクアマンというね 人間なんですね
だから人間ですけど このアトランティスの海の中に住んでいるいた
沖崎と人間と結婚して一緒になって生まれた子供で
この子供にはまあ水の中でも陸上でも何でもできる大物
すごい力がある人で やがてアトランティス国を抑えてそちらの王様になりますけどね
だから一個の場面もリアルはないんですね
あらゆる工夫して 本当にものすごい画面ごとに美しいんですよ
よくも人間がここまで
だって戦争とか水の中に海の中で起こるんだから
そこであらゆる世に存在しない動物たちが乗ってくる
だからアトランティスの人々は
だからもうそこまでもう恐ろしく苦労して
この神話物語を作るんですね
それにもまた現代的に
ニュース番組でこういうこういう事件が起きちゃって
これはまあまあ これ自然的な津波ではないかとかね
言ったりと 誰かさんがね
いえ それはアトランティスの人々が海の中でやったことを言ったら
その人からかわれて もうあなたもう頭おかしいやとかね
そういうふうにリアルなものもちょこちょこと出したりして
またリアルなものはおかしくて
本当にアンリアルな神話物語の方が正しいっていうふうな映画が組み立てているんですね
だからまとめてみたら
まあ子供が見ても見ていいような
別に何のアドバイスもない
もうごく普通に この自分の画像作りの技を出している映画なんですね
だからこれ 最近の映画でしょうね
最近は まあまあ そんなに古くはないと思いますけどね
で で そんなにはエイリアンが出てくる映画やらエイリアンと戦う映画やら
もういくら何でもありますよ
もうそれからこのドラキュラではなくて
こういうね まあ映画で言ったらもう検索すれば出る
は出るはいくらでも 狼男たちの映画見たければいくらでもありますね
それからゾンビの映画も
まああるはあるわ どう人間それが好きなんですね
それで私は映画ならアホでなければならないいけないという自分なりの哲学を作っているんです
だから真面目に本物のリアルな人間の出来事について参考にして書いている映画を私は見ないんです
リアルな映画じゃないんだと
そんなのは ドキュメンタリーみたいにもドキュメンタリーにはならない
だって映画だからね だからあんなのはゴミ
誰かがリアルな人のキャラで
だったらドキュメンタリー作ってくださいと
勉強になりますよという私は変な思考を持ってるんですね
これは正しいわけじゃないんだけど
ということは 人間にはこの神話好きということはね
なんかみんなにあるんですね
神話がない国がないんですよ
日本の国の歴史は何なのかというと
まるっきりひと欠けらも事実でない神話物語を持ってくるんです
全く嘘ばっかりで でも誰も嘘やと思わない
だからスリランカ人 自分の国のスリランカ人がどうやって現れたのかと言っちゃうと
あれはライオンとオキサキが交尾して現れた民族やと
ありえないでしょうね
でもそれに悪口言っちゃうと
みんな機嫌が悪くなるんですね
しかし 実際土を掘ってみると
別に普通に進化してきたホモ・サピエンス時代から進化してきた人々の歴史があるんですよ
石器時代があったり いろんな武器を作ったりして
いろんなものを愛用して
じわじわじわじわと文化を作った人間の歴史が出てくるんですけど
なかなか人気ない それは
リアルな歴史には それで私は 2つ考えているんですね
子供の神話と大人の神話
子供の神話は子供の頃
それがなければ もう子供を育てていることできないんですよ
子供は小さい時にこういう物語を教えてあげると
本気でそれ本物だと思う
だから夜寝ていて怖くなったりもするんですね
あのキャラが出てきて
しかし ちょこちょこと大きくなってくると
きれいさっぱりそれ忘れちゃうんです
だから 私と日本の子供たちが何人かすごい猛烈に喧嘩したことがあるんです
それで私はこのサンタさんというのは完璧インチキ嘘だと言ったんです
あんた恥ずかしくないの？あんな嘘に騙されちゃってとかね
ああ 気持ち悪いよと言われて
かなりやられたんです
子供たちは子供たちで絶対攻撃するんです
サンタさんはいるんだと
私は証拠は？だって私はこういうこういうおもちゃが欲しかったんだけどね
ちゃんとそれをその日でありましたからね
だからいるに違いありません
子供に証拠はあるんです
自分がどんなおもちゃが欲しかったかということ誰も知らない
両親以外はね だからなんで朝がこれあるのかと
やっぱりサンタさんがいる
そういうふうにして ちょこっと大きくなっちゃうと
また私も恨みあるんだから
あんた昔こういう話したでしょうにと
今どうだいと また再びあれ古い停戦になった戦争をまたスタートして
私は勝ちたいんだけど
忘れているんです 私と喧嘩したことも
だからもう私 結局結果として私は負けたことになるんですね
だって再び戦争を引き起こして
もう勝ちたかったのに
向こうはそんなことあったけど
覚えてもないんですね
ということで 子供たちっていうのは大きくなると
あんなシンデレラ物語なんかはね
ひと欠けらも信じません
宝探しやあれやこれは全部子供たちにはこのもうもう本だけの話なんですね
実際はないんです それは子供の物語
そこでいくらが子供が抑えてきますから
遊んでくれるんだから
親にとっても助かります
次に大人の物語 大人の神話
それって大変なんです
大人の神話 大人が大人の神話だから
大人がこれを本物だと死ぬまで信じているんです
だから大人の神話はもう大人がもう否定しません
ずっと これはリアル現実だと
ということは 神話知りたがるのは病気だというならば
大人は治らないんですね
だから子供は子供の神話捨てちゃいますけど
大人になっていくと 大人の神話を
に入れ替えちゃうんです
そこで映画などの世界で
映画 本 小説などの漫画とか世界でもまた神話の働きはあるんだけど
そこはそんなに問題ではありませんね
例えば漫画にしても映画にしても
いかに人間に妄想できるのかと
だからそこら辺の勝負なんですね
どれぐらい巧みに嘘をつけるのかと
で それでも商売になって金儲かっちゃいますから
全然大丈夫です 金儲かる手段だからね
たまに人は病気になりますよ
例えばエイリアンの映画ありますよ
エイリアンの映画っていうのは相当怖いんですよ
あれはもう CG は 全く本物のように作るんだから
あんな化け物にこの CG で
何て言いますか このいろいろ感情表現までさせるんだから
冗談じゃないんです ワニの化け物が来たっても
ちゃんと感情の表現するんです
動物の中ではありえないでしょうに
だから相当能力なんですね
しかし 気が弱い人々は
姿勢が弱い人々はそれによって病気になっちゃって
で エイリアンが確実に攻撃しているんだ
もうかなり前 かなりって言ったって
もう私は日本にいた時から
まあまあ 10年間の年齢
年代を覚えてないんだけど
こういう宗教あったんですよ
なんか白装束と言ったら
みんな白い服を着て なんとか宇宙のどこかの星から放射線を送って人間
の世界を攻撃しようとしているんだと
だから自分が頑張って
自分の身を張って もう人類を守っているんだと
だから女ですけど その悪
悪い放射線全部自分で受け止けて
自分がまあ今末期がん状態になっているんだと言って
これたくさんもう300 400 500人ぐらい男たちがその女性のお世話をしながら
パラグライダーあちら行ったりこちらへ行ったり
だから宇宙のエイリアンの
放射をね カットするために
何でも白い布でかぶっておくんですね
だからみんな信じていたんですよ
私が考えたのは 遠い遠いね
もう 100 光年も 200 光年も遠いところの星団から出てくる放射線がそこまで届けますけど
たった白い服に当たったところでストップするんですね
すごい力ですね あの白い服には
服というのは布切れには
でも日本人 それ信じていたんです
あの信仰者たちが 我々知っているレントゲンでもね
あの白い服を白い布切れ一つ前に入れたからといって
あれは通っちゃいますよ
レントゲンのあれってものすごく弱いんですよ
遠く行かないんです でも
その人々もちゃんと大学出て
科学出て エンジニア出ている人々ですよ
でもやっぱりみんな白い服を着ていると
宇宙から来る悪い放射線から身を守られるとと思っているという
だからこれはそういう病気になる
時々日本で悪魔に神様の指令だからといって人を殺したりする
だから神話好きだったら
このなんとか全く SF 映画を見ればいいのに
ああいう風になってくると病気になるんですね
で 危険なところもあります
はい それで大人の神話の 2番目っていうのは宗教なんです
だから宗教はいらんと言ったら
こんなけしからな人間存在しないっていう風に非難を受けます
世の中で アメリカ大統領はどんな宗派のどんなキリスト教であるか
それによって大統領として選ばれるんです
プロテスタントやカトリック教かとかね
だから黒人一人殺した最近のケースでも
大統領はめげない やったことは正しいと顔をしてみんなにカメラの前で聖書を見せてニコッと笑っているんですね
だからあんなインチキ本を見せたら
全部解決すると思っているんですね
しかし もしアメリカの大統領
こんなのは嘘だ 私は科学信じますよ
あの聖書を捨てたら 次の日
大統領辞めなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
大騒ぎになるんです だから
神話信じなさいよと 神話こそが本物だっていうことが何かすごく大事になってるんです
だからいまだに科学 科学は何かよその
いわゆる家族で言えば
夫婦喧嘩 結婚して生まれた男息子とお父さんがどこかで隠れて作った息子で
二人も認定しています
私の息子やと でも一人が結婚していない女から生まれたんだから
英語の単語はバスタードと言いますけど
日本語で何と言うかわからないんだけど
そういう立場なんですね
だからこの王家の場合はね
あのちゃんと王様とお妃に生まれた子供は次の王になるんだけど
王様が別なところでこの子供より先に子供を作ってあっても
王にならないんですね
バスタードだから だから科学の立場はそんな程度なんですね
だから 例えばすべて神が作ったと言って
神が物事をすべて作るんだったら
神は全知全能でなければいけませんね
神様 ある神様が上げて
ある程度で力があって
ある程度の世界は作れますと言っちゃうとあまり良くない
だから全知全能の神が神が完璧な神がもう森羅万象を創造しましたと
いて 現実的に森羅万象を見ると
まあ酷でもない世界なんですね
不完全で不完全でどうしようもないんですね
弱肉強食で成り立っているんですね
悪人が生存して善人が潰れてしまう世界システムなんですね
それどう説明するのかと
あ まずいね これは 神が作った世界は完璧なはずなんです
それが新しいストーリーを作るんです
いえ あの神に逆らったバカがいるんだよと
サタンという あいつは神に隠れていたずらして
こういう風に変なことにしているんだと
だから生きている人間の仕事は
徹底的にサタンを叩いて破って殺すことなんですね
だから人間にはサタン見えませんだから神を信じていない人々を殺しに行くんです
そこでこのいくら今サタンが勝ち続くです
勝ち続けていても やがて神様が勝つんだそうです
やがて 神様がマリファナでも吸って寝ているかどうかよくわからないんですね
こっちは困ってるんだけど
あのサタンの誘惑で 俺
正気マッスルにならなくちゃ
もう神様があのマリファナはもう一応
もしかするともう 1万キロぐらい長いかもね 1
万か もうもう 1億キロぐらいね
だから吸って吸って終わったら出てくるんです
あ 終わっちゃった ではサタンを首を絞めてやるぞとか
でも人間があの神話物語を真面目に信じるんです
それ教会で あの あのワイングラスをなんかオイナルしながら上まで回しちゃうんですね
回しちゃうと それは確実にイエスの血に入れ替えるんだそうです
だから懺悔していないと絶対あれはあげませんよ
だからイエスの肉と血を食べてどうなるんです？イエスは神ですけど
で そこを成り立たないって
こんな神話の場合は何でもOKなんです
だからOKなんです あのトムとジェリーの漫画の場合は
あのもう 山から落ちるわ
もう車にはねられるわ
もうぺっちゃんこで知りませんね
あの犬がいて 犬の鼻から入って口から出たりする
あのネズミが大丈夫なんです
それで犬の目からネズミが顔を出してみる場合もありますね
だから漫画だからこれ大丈夫なんです
だから大人の神話物語も大丈夫です
イエスさん肉食ってあるそうと言ったあれば
残酷じゃないんです キャニバリズムではないんです
それによって魂が清めて天界で永遠の命になる
で 例えば このキリスト教
ユダヤ教 イスラム教の神様っていうのは
男性の生殖器官にすごい興味を持っているんですね
全て作った神がなんであんなちっちゃな部品にそんなに興味を持ってるんですかね
調べるんですよ ちゃんと括約しているかないかとか
それやってないと イスラム教とユダヤ教ではもう天国に行くことできん
もしかすると最後の審判でみんな裸にして男たちを調べていくでしょうね
で でも誰もそんなのは変って思わないんですね
それでイスラム教では
この動物食うならば イスラムの宗教の人が宗教のお祈り歌って動物を殺さなくちゃいけないんですね
普通の店でやる肉食べてはいけないんです
食べたら地獄に落ちるんです
だからちゃんとハラールした肉を食べるんですね
それでハラールの決まりは何かとじきじき聞いたら
この首を一発で切らなくちゃいけない
それにはそれなりの訓練が必要です
牛と牛の喉はちょっと大きいんだからね
だから刃物でピシッと切らなくちゃいけない
で それであの裏返しして足でぶら下がって
全部血を体から出ていくまで待たなくちゃいけないんですね
だから首を切っただけでも死なないんだから
あの体の細胞は働いてますね
だからどんどんどんどん血が流れて流れて出ていったら
この血を食べてはいけないんだそうです
だから肉も結構洗っちゃいますね
それに悪口を言うと この人々は
科学的に科学の教えになるんです
あの人に病気がうつる場合は
血液と経由でうつるんだよと
さすがアッラーがそれ知っていたんだよという
だから この生命の肉の体に悪いところは全部血液の中で流れているんだ
だから神様が全知全能だからそれを抜けてくださいと
言ったら だったら現代は血液の成分で薬まで作ってますけど
それにあなたはどうするのかと言ったら
イスラム教はそういう薬使っちゃいけないっていう風に終わってしまうんですね
で まあそんなもんですね
だから神話信じるとすごい立派な人間になります
そこでこの面白いことは
あの神話を嘘だと捨てちゃうと
シンデレラ物語と小人おじいさんの物語と同じだと言っちゃうと
宗教が世界から消えてしまうんですね
別に悪く 別にどうったことないんだけどね
だからそれの問題が宗教はいるかいらないかっていう問題が出てくるんですね
それってよくわからないんですね
人類に宗教がいるかいらないかと
なぜかっていうと わからないっていうのは
この宗教の人々は我々はここまで人類のために頑張ったぞと言うんですよ
だからあんな宣教 PR に乗るのかと
本当に頑張ったのかと
魔女狩りやったり 王様たちをクーデターで殺したりとかね
よくやってるんですよ
もう で だから隣人愛しなさいよとかね
困っている人を助けてくださいよとかね
そういう風な なんとなくまあ悪くない教えもあるんですね
でもこの悪くない教えも
もう全く悪い神秘の上に乗せちゃうと
もう意味がないんですね
例えば隣人愛するのはなぜ？神様が決めたから
決めなかったら別にということになるでしょうに
だから隣人愛することに
ある道徳的なこのパワーが機能が宗教絡んでいて弱くなるんですね
例えば 良い人間に生活することは
地球上でだいたい結構人間頑張ってますよ
人を助けたり 良いことをしたりは
しかし それはイスラムの方々の目から見ると
イスラム人でない場合はあんまり大したことはないんです
そういうふうに そこで価値が低く見てしまうんですね
天国に行くチャンスの場合は
やっぱりユダヤ人の方はもう特権で
初めからもう天国に行くことは決まっている
だからユダヤ人なら何やってもいいんですね
そういうふうに なんかいいのか悪いのかよくわからないっていう状態もありますね
それで ヒンドゥー教 もろもろのキリスト教
もろもろのイスラム教
それから昔あったゾロアスター教などなどの古い宗教
今ない それから日本の神道とかね
すべて神話は外しちゃうと潰れてしまいます
ということは 神話は嘘でしょ？どういうこと？嘘でなければ成り立たないんですね
そこで仏教が面白いんです
仏教も流行に乗るんです
それで何なのかと そこで仏教文献ももうキリスト教のギリシア人にはもう全く能力できない
もう想像イメージできないぐらい莫大な神話世界を作っているんです
これでもかと だって仏教のお釈迦様がいつでもものすごい荒廃でしたっけ？派手な六
光を放ちながら なんかもうもうあの夜
あの夜間野球場の照明灯みたいな感じで光り放って歩いてるんだから
じゃあどうだいと イエスできないでしょ
他の宗教はそんなキャラはないんですね
でもあれほどこのもう
照明 あのライトハウスみたいに光り放っていた存在なのに
インド人はブッダのこと知らないんです
インドから仏教は消えているんです
そんなことあったら信じるはずでしょうに
なんであんなストーリー作るんですかね
だからパーリ仏教をいくらか参考にしていかにいかれているのかということを説明しますけど
大乗仏教はもう話にならん
もう神話抜けちゃうと大乗仏教はないんです
観音さんがいるわ もう不動さんがいるわ
もう大日如来がいるわ
もう全部化け物だけで成り立っているんですね
歴史的な人物はいません
歴史的な人物を見たら
みんな立派な人々なんですよ
日本を見たら 例えば道元禅師とかね
本当に立派なもう先輩ね
すごい もう当てになる勉強になる先輩方々はいますけど
でもそれじゃなくて もうお化け信仰するんだから
だから聖職者にもそれ便利なんです
自分がいくらだらしなくても
本尊 本尊 本尊はもう本尊が観音さんだからね
大丈夫です ご利益ある観音様ですからね
坊主は何やっても 例えば試しに私ならそういうものが神話ものが作るんだけど
このご本尊にはすごい力があるんだよと
3日  3日お祈りしたら万病はすべて治りますよと
しかし ご本尊を守っているお坊さんが厳しく道徳を守って
朝から晩までこういうふうな生き方しなきゃ汚れて終わりだと
だから人が来て 3 日間お祈りしても
病気治るところ あった病気もちょっと大きくなったならば
だって薬飲まなくて病気が悪化しますからね
ほら あの住職がね って言えますから
そうすると人間が困りますから
住職さんがね だから逆に御本山
ご本尊には力があって
それは永久的にあります
そういうふうにこの仏教の世界も全部神話物語
要するに嘘でできているんです
で 生きていた理由は この薬の実験をするときでも
本物の薬を患者さんにあげながら
一つのグループにはプラシーボというインチキ薬あげるんですね
そこで実験の薬は100人に飲ませて
インチキ薬を100人に飲ませてみてデータを取ったら
大体インチキ薬の人々も治りますね
統計を見たら どちらの方がよくわからない程度で五分五分なんです
こちらで 30%治りましたと
プラシーボでも 30%治りました
それでも金かかってるんだから
だからこの薬はよろしいと決めちゃうんです
だからこの神話物語のこのプラシーボ効果がありますからね
そう簡単にはなくならない
もう一つは 文学的にどうしても神話物語は楽しいんですよ
だから人間が死んでから地獄に落ちる
天国にはやっぱりわからんだけど
物語は楽しいんですよ
だからお寺に行ったら
もう教会に行ったって同じことで
かなり力つけて派手に物語をよく言うんですね
それでインド文化ではヒンドゥー教という
最近ヒンドゥー教と名前をつけているインド宗教あるんですね
インド人の宗教とインド人の宗教
言ったっても これは一貫してない
もう様々な信仰 様々な修行法
様々なしきたり もうたくさんなりますよ
もうもうどちらかどちらか分からないぐらい複雑なんですけど
で まとめて面倒くさいんだからヒンドゥー教と言うんですね
だからもうもう 100万ぐらい宗教たくさん
宗教は一つにカテゴライズしているんですね
ヒンドゥー教で このバラモン系の流れの宗教は
バラモン人の宗教の大元は
このヴェーダ聖典なんですね
ヴェーダ聖典読んでみると
まあ宗教的な教えはないんです
ただ自然に感謝している作品なんですね
自然の偉大なる力 敵わない力を感じて
それでもおかげさまで生かされているんだっていうとこは
ものすごく美しいかどうかはわからんだけど
面倒くさい サンスクリット語はすごい難しいんだから読みたくないだけでね
本当にいい作品なんですけどね
古い かなり古い作品だからね
理解するのは難しいんです
で 歌っているだけなんです
そこでこれは宗教書にするんですね
そこで梵天の神から 仙人たちが直々聞いて書いたんだと
モーセとモーセも歴史的な人物じゃないんです
後で誰かがモーセというキャラを作って
そちらにはもう昔のエッセイが作ったで
それだけなんです だから後でバラモン人たちがこのアッタカ
バーマカ バーマデーヴァ
サーミット ヤマタ アンギーラス
バーラッドワージャバフというね
リストがありましてね
で 神様が直々語ったと真面目に信じているんですよ
だから神の言葉だから
バラモンカースト以外は聞くなよと
それで自分の社会差別を正当化するために
あの誰かが書いた文学作品を使っているんです
あれ 誰かがではなくて
いろんな人が芸一つ 芸一つ
芸一つ サンスクリット語の場合
唱歌と言うんですけど
ヴェーダ聖典の場合はマントラと言うんですね
マントラ一つ一つつなげてつなげて
膨大なあの本になったんですね
それを人種差別に使う
社会差別に使うという一箇所にあるみたいんですよ
このシュードラカーストの人に間違ってでもヴェーダ聖典を唱えるのを聞こえたら
海に鉛を入れ 耳に鉛を入れて聞こえないようにしてくださいと
だからやってはないんですが
この 気持ちは そんなことやった形式はないんです
ね だからユダヤ法律によってイエス様はもしいたならば
イエス様を死刑に決めるならば
ユダヤ法律では死刑に決める罪を犯っていないんです
それでも死刑に決めるのは石を投げて殺さなくちゃあかんです
十字架で首を成り立たないんです
で イスラム人がそれを真面目にやりたがっているんですね
ユダヤ人は自分の宗教でやらない
しかし 石を投げて殺すべきだと大事に書いておく
でもこれは後ろで一言も言えません
だから覚悟の上で神に逆らっているんです
神が女の人は他の男の方を見たら石投げて殺せと言っているのに
やってないでしょ やってないから
あれは神が間違ったと言えば簡単でしょうに
神がマリファナ飲み過ぎてやったと
その時は言っちゃえば簡単万事解決なのに
え？神の言葉はそのまま確か正しい
だったらやってない やらないことは神を冒涜することでしょう
で イスラム教は何としてでもそれをまた再び実行しようと頑張っているんですね
はい まあ仏教に戻ります
で そういうことで 仏教にもいっぱいあの神話物語がありましてね
ゆめちがい観音もいるしね
勘違い観音はいないんですね
なぜならばまとめて勘違いだからね
だからすべての観音様たちの総合結果は勘違い観音ですから
ゆめちがい観音とか ちっちゃな仕事柄に分けて分けています
だからキリスト教だったら
イエスが救済人を救ってくるための優しい存在で
仏教の場合は阿弥陀さんですね
阿弥陀さんというか 阿弥陀さんの仕事は人が死ぬ瞬間待っていて
魂を持っていくんですね
なんとかどこかに そうすると
阿弥陀様はなんか神の
雇われている状態なんですね
ちょっとまずいね これは
やっぱり絶対的なものを作ったんです
大地の子らという こんな嘘を言わなきゃ仏教成り立たないんですかね
そこであのインドの 場合はもう一つまずいことがあるんです
あ インド教の場合は このそうやって神話で宗教出来上がったんです
だから神話がないと宗教も終わり
だからそこでお釈迦様ちょっとからかったことがありますよ
あなた方 こういうアッタカなどなどの仙人たち
直々聞いたと話でしょ
そこで調べてくださいと
このアッタカはじめの仙人たちが私が聞きましたと書いてますかと
書いてないんです だからお釈迦様がなんとなく知ったんですよ
この神話のどうやって現れるのかと
もう一つ 釈迦様からかってこう言うんですね
もし神が直々仙人たちに言ったとしましょう
聞き違いしたらどうする？だから聞いて伝わると話は汚染されてどんどん退化していくっていうことは自然法則で
お釈迦様はそれ知っているんです
はい それでインド文化でもう一つ問題がありまして
インドっていうのは このかなり昔からも知識人もいるんです
完璧 大馬鹿者たちも半分以上いるんだけど
ものすごい知識人も一部グループいるんですね
なかなかもう中国にも負けない
エジプトにも負けない
ギリシャに負けない知識人もいるんですね
知識人にとっては この教育を次の次の世代に教えなくちゃあかんのです
ヴェーダ聖典は丸暗記すればいいのです
しかし 数学 政治学 法律
農学 特に人間関係の場合は政治学
それから人間の人格 どうやって教えるのかと
単純に人を騙すなよ けしからんと子供に言っても
聞いてくれるわけないんです
お父さん でも面白いよ
あいつを騙してね こんなことをしてあいつを騙してね
こんなひどい目に遭わせてよかった
楽しい 楽しかったと言うんだから
結構子供たちはやりますよ
この木の上でリス リスが巣を作ってるんだから
君登って取ってくださいと言って
自分たちサポートして登らせる
枝に乗った途端 子供たちは逃げる
じゃあどうしますかって
あの子 降りられなくなっちゃうんで
それでギャーギャーギャー泣いて泣いて泣いて
もうもうあまり大人もいないところで子供が遊ぶんだからね
相当ひどい目に遭ってから大人が来て
子供を木から降ろして家に連れてきますけどもね
やった連中がそれで喜んでいるんです
だからだいたい子供の性格はそんなもんだから
おとなしくしなさいって通じません
そんなのは 人に迷惑かけるなよと言っても通じません
それで使った教育手段は物語なんです
同じく神話は物語なんです
そこで物語の中で子供たちはよだれ垂らしながら聞いてるでしょ
裏で生き方がサブリミナル的にね
心に入っちゃうんです
ですから このホリウッド映画と違って
何も教えてくれないでしょ？アメリカ人ほど偉い人間がいませんよと
我こそ神様というメッセージしか何もないんです
インドのあのストーリーの中で
そうじゃなくて 何か間接的に心に訴えちゃうんです
これは信仰じゃないんです
例えば友達が友達を裏切ること
いかに良くないのかと
ストーリーを作るんです
このストーリーでもライオンがいるわ
雄牛さんがいるわ 面白いことに
このライオンと牛さんがえらい仲良し
普段だったらライオンは牛を食べてこれで食べるんだけど
ストーリーだから そこでだからそれ変なことはこう
面白いんですよ え？ライオンと牛さんが友達？友達よ
普段は食べますよ でも友達だから食べなかったよ
そこで何か学んでいるでしょう
牛さんのことをすごく心配しているんだと
いくらなんでも牛さんにはもうもうもう怪我一つもさせませんでした
友達だから 友達だからね
それで子供たちはものすごい膨大な言葉にならない人格学ぶ
そこでキツネさんがね
ジャッカルが来て 牛が見た
結構肉ついてる牛ですね
１週間分の肉があるんだから
でもこいつはジャッカルにはね
牛を殺せませんだから
ちっぽけな犬みたいな犬だから
だから牛を殺すのはライオンですけど
え？この二人が仲良く一緒に座って寝ているんだと
互いに舐め上がったりまでして
え？だからこの肉食えない １
週間分の肉無駄 ということで
ジャッカルが長い時間かけて組み立てるんです
なんとかライオンが狩りに行く時は脇にいてどけさせて
王様ありがとうございます
お元気で長生きしましょうねと挨拶したり
毎日やってるんだから
もうライオンも まあまあいいや
もうなんか私のこと気に入ってるみたいとかね
そういう感じでライオンの仲良しになる
そこでもう牛もそばにいる
ジャッカルもそばにいる
そこでこそこそこそこそとすごい時間かけて
牛の悪口を言うんですね
ライオンに悪口言ったっても届きませんだから
どう見ても王様は体格的にはあなたの友達の方が大きいでしょう
ライオンっていうのはそんなに体格はないんだからね
なんか二人が一緒にいて
どちらが王様か分からなくなりますよと
牛かライオンか ライオンより2倍3倍くらい体が大きいんだからね
牛が そんな風に話を持っていって
ゆっくりと 牛の狙いはライオンを殺して百獣の王になることやと
ライオンはそんな嘘言うなよと
あいつは友達ね ありえない
そんなことはと ああ そう
まあいいや 私はどうせキツネだからね
私のこと信頼しないんだからね
とか言ってね じゃあ明日見てくださいと
あなたは挨拶に来るときは
そいつは首を下げてすねを向けてきてくるはずですよ
その角 頭下がったら 角が
前に来るんだからね そこでライオンにこう言うんですね
私の話があなた信じなかったら
明日牛さんが来るとね
ちょっと手上げてみてくださいと
すねを出して いわゆる攻撃するような感じで
友達だったら あんた何やってるの？というと
それでいいでしょ だから大丈夫ですよと
友達同士でね もう刀持っててめえを殺してやるとか
ガチャガチャやったら気にもしないでしょ
うん で 牛のところに行って
また同じような話をして
あなたを殺しに計画立ててますよと
だから いえ ありえません
じゃあ明日あんた見てください
ライオンがあなた見ただけで
こうやって手を挙げてすねを出すんだよと
そばに来たら攻撃する印やと
だからあなたが初めからもう頭を下げて
惨めな姿で明日挨拶に行ってください
でなきゃあなた大変やと
そこでああ わかりました
私はあのライオン様を迷惑かけたくはないんだから
もうどんな風にでもまあ惨めな姿を見せましょうと言って
牛さんが最初からはすごく体も控えめて
頭ものすごく下げて 首をね
ものすごく下げてライオンのところに行くんですね
ライオンを見たら こいつは言った通りに攻撃態勢で来るんだよと
こちらも手を上げて そこでお互い当たっちゃって牛が死んじゃうんですね
ライオンが肉もライオンじゃなくてキツネが肉食べますけど
後でライオン え？何ようなことやったのかと
これってありえないんだと
私がすごい間違いを犯しましたと
後の祭りなんですね はい
このストーリーで子供たちにどれぐらいことを学べると思う
そこで今私は省略して言ったんだけど
これ本一冊ぐらい分厚いストーリーなんです
このストーリーの中で
このサブストーリー ストーリーたくさんあるんです
だから一年二年かかりますね
子供たちに教える場合は
もう本終わると子供たちは立派な大人になっているんです
人間の関係 友達のありがたさ
友達を裏切ってはいけないこと
あんまりデータ調べないで
人の噂聞いて 判断を起こしたらいかに危険かと
そんなのは社会学授業で教えたっても理解してくれんでしょ
だから現代の子供たちは完璧バカでしょ
ストーリーは教えてくれない
社会の勉強はあれやこれやとか
全く面白くない方法で教えているんでしょうね
そういうわけで ストーリーっていうのはそう簡単に捨てられ捨てられるものじゃないんです
心の人格向上にはものすごい効き目のある
手段なんです だから人類から神話物語り消してやろうっていうこともできない
だからインドでは無駄話と有意義な話に二つ分けています
シンデレラ物語は まあある程度で頑張るっていうところではちょっと役に立つかもしれませんだけど
頑張ったら何でも万々歳でついてくるんだよっていうのは
あれは嘘 それはアメリカ文化で人を潰して
もうアメリカンドリームっていう
それじゃなくて 人間死ぬまでコツコツと頑張らなくちゃいけない
まあそれはそれで で ストーリーにはそれなりの
役目があるんです だからその役目が
例えば薬にはすごい大事な役目があるんです
しかし 薬がちょっと間違ったら人は死ぬんです
だから薬を使う場合は
ものすごい丁寧に専門家が推薦するべきです
お医者さんがこのこの薬か
使ってください 書いてもまた薬剤師がそれを読んで
またあなたの体調はどうですか？もう食べるものは何？また調べて薬をあげなくちゃいけない
な それで人は治ります
ちょっと間違っちゃうと死にます
だから物語 神話っていうのはそういう二キャラをやっているんです
そこで人間があの悪キャラだけを受け取っているんです
物語からはすごい子供たちに教育的に役に立ちますよというところは
いらない そんな嘘の物語を聞くなよと偉そうに言って
こいつは日曜日教会に行く
行ってあの小麦粉で作ったパン食ってくるんです
あの水をかけたらすべて罪が消えると思っているんです
インド人もそうですよ
ガンジス川に飛び込んだら
すべて罪が消えても消えるんです
しかし 罪が溶かすほどのパワーがある
ガンジス川には 特に 徳はどうなる？消えちゃうでしょ
その理論は使わないんです
あの 我々は服汚れたら漂白剤というか
キッチンハイター入ったキッチン
ハイター使うんですね
真っ白くなるんです 全部垢が消えちゃって
でも色柄付いてるもの入れてください
真っ白くなるんだけど
色柄も消えちゃうんです
色柄欲しいんだけど もうダメです
だからあんなガンジス川のキッチンハイターの川に人が飛び込んだら
罪だけじゃなくて線も消えるんですよ
でも神話信仰だからね
罪だけ選んで選んで 川がこれは善行
いや これを置いておいて
これは悪行為 はい これ洗い流してしまった
すごい判断能力がありますよ
ガンジス川のあの泥水に
だからこの大人の神話っていうのは役に立った
そんなことは 人が死んじゃったら燃えて灰をガンジス川に流したら
直行で天国 灰が天国に行く位置ありますかね
海に行くか 海まで行かないんだからね
すぐ最近 このマハトマガンディーさんのね
灰の一部をアフリカでミニアフリカで見つけてね
大騒ぎになっちゃって
それでもう孫時代の親戚が入って
正式にこの灰の骨壺を持ってきて
この流しちゃったんです
今まで守ったのは一応保管してあったのにね
かわいそうね 今そこ見つかるまでガンジーさんがね
天国に行けなくちゃって
ね 灰の一部が なんだこれはっていうふうに思っちゃいますけど
だから 昔 あの学者のグループが分厚い作品を作ったんです
あれは えっと あの なんて言いますかね
あの歴史物語 全部頭で妄想したものなんです
ものすごい分厚いな本なんです
だから一人には書けませんよ
いろんな人が書いて出して
書いて出して これはなんとなくバラタという王子たちの物語
これ読んでる人々 この作品だからそれだけでしょ
どんどんインド人がインドがバラタ国であると勘違いしちゃって
今 インドの正式名前はバラ
インドっていうのはインドス川の東ということで
もうあのあの人殺し作った名前ですけどね
アレクサンダー アレクサンダー
別にインドという国はないんですよ
それそれぞれの国 国の名前があったんです
それでアレクサンダーがインドっていう国作ったところで
私たちはマハバーラという風にまた
それはそれで そこでこの王子たちの話だから
戦争があるんですね どうしても
それで戦争で人を戦わなくちゃいけない
残念ながらこの親戚同士の戦争なんです
そうすると この 善役のキャラはね
若い王子ですね 悪役のキャラたちは年取ってるおじいさんたちなんですね
おじいさんたちの王子たちで
なんで人を殺さなくちゃいけない
なんでこんな無駄な戦争をするのかと
この人悩むんです 何なんだかこれはと
おじいさんとか 国を取って政治したければやればいいでしょうにと
なんで俺はおじいさんたちを殺して私の国にしなくちゃあかんかと
だからそこで戦争っていうのはいかなる無知アホな行為でしょうかと
ちょっと悩みが心に入るんです
いわゆる超現代的な思考が入っちゃったんです
あ これは危険 やっぱり神話物語の世界が必要です
これであの王子の車を運転している運転手が
この人は悩んでるということをわかって
すーっと喋るんです 説教するんです
講演一つやるんです いかに戦争が大事かと
人殺すことを大事だよって言ってのは
まともな人に言えないでしょ
だからものすごくインド人
知識人だから この世界は一時的なもの
そこでいろんなものが起こる
しかし 魂は永遠のもの
魂は神のもの 神が魂に泥を塗って
いろいろ人間を作る場合は
神がそのその体にこれやってほしいと
この人間劇場でね あなたはこのキャラ
あなたはこのキャラで
神がこのドラマのスクリプトライターでステージマネージャーでプロデューサーなんですね
全部自分でやっているんです
だから神が各人間に役柄を決定しているんだから
あなたはその役柄やらないと
成り立たんでしょうにと
あんたがこの肉体を大事に思って
私私と思ってるでしょうにと
冗談じゃないやと あんた
神が作ったこの人類劇舞台で
この一つのキャラだけだと
だから自分のキャラやって
何て言いますか パーッとやってくださいよと
神が決めたセリフを言って
それを真面目にやったら
みんな万々歳で拍手するでしょ
神様がそれで喜ぶでしょうにと
それこそ神様に対する尊敬であり
儀式儀礼であり 神様に対する感謝であると
だからこれで終わり お前王子だから
王子の仕事は人殺すこと
その講演というか 説法
説教が今バガヴァッドギーターというヒンドゥー教の聖書になっているのです
何の道徳もないんだけど
哲学はあるのです 道徳はないんだけど
あれは文学作品と言った途端
ヒンドゥー教は壊れるでしょう
本当に文学作品なんです
インド人も私より知っています
私はマハーバーラタの一部は読んでみようかなと思って読んだんだけど
お釈迦様は読まないと禁止しているんだから
何かとなく悪いことするのも何か刺激がありますからね
読んでみて やっぱりこれは一般的な人間が読む本じゃないと言ってやめたんです
すごく頭がおかしくなるんですよ
ですから このヒンドゥー教にしたっても
神話物語がなければ宗教は成り立たないんですね
だから神話物語捨てちゃえって捨てられませんね
教育的な...役目もあります
で その中で危険でないのは
このたとえ話なんですね
日本にあるたとえ話は
矢を一本だったらカチッと割れるとね
本まとめたらなかなか割れませんよとね
折れません  折れませんと
で まあそんなのは日本日本の発明ではなく
そんなどこでもそういう話がありますからね
まああんまり大したこと
まあそういうのは失礼ですけど
たとえ話大事ですよ だからインド文化でもスリランカ文化でその例あるんです
あの金の卵を何でしたっけ？ 雌鶏です
雌鶏 で 古いストーリーなの例え話じゃないんですね
それでやがてどうなったのかというと
全部パーになっちゃったんですね
なんで？欲張ったから
だから与えられたもんで生活しなさいと
たとえ恵まれたバカであっても
与えられたもので満足しないと
全てパー あれ一言で見事に...言ってますから
だから金の卵を産む雌鶏の話では
人は精神的に病気にならない
初めから私は知ってますからね
知ってれば知ってますから
だから 天地創造論っていうのは
人類にとってはとても危険なもの
ストーリーで 金の卵を産む雌鶏は
人類にとってとってもありがたいストーリーなんです
どちらが尊敬される？天地創造
こんなもんで 人間の状況は
そういうわけで 仏教には神話物語は入らないわけないでしょ
インド文化だから物語は入らないわけないでしょ
だから特別文学セクションあるんです
ジャータカ物語という
しかし 経典には物語がないんです
ジャータカパーリというんです
だから 後の人々にマヌブタラに一緒のことを教えても
ジャータカパーリっていうのは
ヴェーダ聖典のマントラと同じ意味で
パーリっていうのはその意味なんです
いわゆるこの人に教える戒め
言葉でまとめて短い言葉で書いているんです
偈一個 偈二個とかね だからこれグループじていますよ
エーカカニパータっていうのは偈一個で一個だけで
あれあれを経文を言う
そこはそれから次は偈二行で
これでもう九まで行っちゃいますね
物語はないんです やれやれと
そこで説法する坊主は自分好きな物語作っちゃえばいいでしょ
自分好きな物語を作って
あの偈をそちらに入れておく
だからストーリーの器は別で作って
このダイヤをその器に乗せるだけで十分です
それで一応伝統的にはもうストーリーもできちゃって
それでジャータカ物語っていうものはある
で ジャータカッタパーリと言うんですけど
まあそれはもう注釈集だからね
もうもう年程度でしょう
年代的には 紀元前600年前のブッダの話は随分時間経ってます
で 仏教徒はあの物語は信じるんだけど
中にある牛はピョッと捨てちゃうんです
バナナの皮を食べて中身を捨てる
だからジャータカ物語は文学作品
それでキャラはいろいろ
どうしても菩薩キャラが必ず来なくちゃあかん
だって菩薩と言ったらこの模範的なキャラになっちゃうんです
だからジャータカ牛が喋るわ
鹿が王様に政治論教えるわ
まああるはあるわ で 狩人がこのすごい立派な象牙のある
あまりにもすごい このびっくりするほど立派な象牙輝いているんです
これを牛を殺して象牙を持っていきたいんですね
それで当然 ゾウさんは菩薩で狩人は大部だったで
それでゾウさんはどこでどこで行くのかで全部チェックして
ルートマップをちゃんと調べて
で その道の中で穴を掘って
それでもう隠れているんですね
それも穴掘ってるっていうことは
この象に気づかないようにいろんな工夫して相当計画立てるんです
だってゾウさんもすごい頭が菩薩だから
ちょっとした視線変化はもう気になるんです
だからあっち枯葉があって
こちらからあちらもあって
こちらもあってって言ったら
別にってことになるでしょ
その一個の中に こいつは毒矢を持って待ってるんです
そこでちゃんとゾウが数えるんです
それから 数えて足の振動でこの象牙持ってる象とそうでない象にかなりしたりするんです
それでいて あ ではない
ここではない ここではないとか言って
あ 今日はダメだって また次の日でまたと
そこでこのゾウの王様がもうドカンドカンと足をつけてくると
振動でわかって 今日は来る
それで振動に乗っていて
ちゃんと自分の前に来たら毒矢を打つんですね
ちゃんと胸に それでもかなり厳しくて死ぬでしょ
でも菩薩だから馬鹿じゃないんです
下から何かあったんだから
だいたい人間っていうのは木の上とかね
いて 嘘でしょ それで木丸ごと取って潰しちゃえばいいんだからね
周り見てもないんだから
こいつは自分を守れると思ったんです
そこで下 鼻を入れてみちゃうと
人間こうやってあげるんですね
菩薩だからこうやって絞め殺さないんですね
そこで なんでお前は私に矢をどこへ撃ったんですかと
象は喋りますよ だからストーリーが必要なんです
ストーリーじゃなきゃ象が喋りません
言ったらこいつは悪人なのに
こいつは嘘言わないんですね
あれがちょっと変なんです
だいぶ雑だからね だからどうしても自分をこうやって捕まってるんだから
嘘言ったって意味がないんだからね
そう 鼻がね ちょっとね
ちっちゃうと終わりですから
それはですね お妃がね
あなたの象牙のことを欲しくて欲しくて持ってきてって言ってるんだから
私は長い間計画を立てて
象を象牙が欲しくてやったと
うん そう そんなにあなたの象牙欲しい？で
菩薩はいいよ 私は座りますから
切って持っていって そこで菩薩はそういうものなんです
あんなに大事なものをそんなに欲しい
はい 持って行って それでこいつは
この原始時代のあれ鋸で切るは切るはどうせ切る場合はね
半分ここら辺で切っちゃうとあれ短くなるんだから
顎のところから切るんです
だから毛がだらけで 象さんが
菩薩はここで耐え 耐えているんです
耐えるんです 私はお布施をして生命を救いましょうと
だから この苦しみに耐えることは私の修行になるんだと
思って耐えているんですね
それで切ると切ると あいつは力が抜けてなかなかできん
だから 2日  3日かけて苦労する必要はないでしょう
そこでもうお前に力ないんだから
私も助けてあげましょう
象さんが自分の鼻の力を入れてあげて
さっさと 象牙 2つを切ってあげたんですね
でも あの苦しみに耐えることができなくて
象さんは亡くなります
それでストーリーなんです
そこで象さんは菩薩で象牙を持っていた狩人が大麻だったり
そこは教育的なストーリーなんです
キリスト教のストーリーよりもはるかに優れています
だから この私が言いたいのは
この仏教徒たちが本当に象さんが喋ったと思っているところが何なのかと
しかし この宗教からこれ受難すること入ってます
あの象さんがあれほどなんで苦しみを受けたんですかというと
人々を救うためなんです
だから こういうのをまとめてキリスト教みたいなどうにもならない当てにならない宗教も出来上がったんだけどね
仏教はあるんだけど そういうのはそんなにハイライトはしないんでしょうしね
しかし ブッダが長い間輪廻転生して修行して
パーラミタ完成して人々を救ってあげたと
イエスさんはたった 1日だけでしょ
1日か 2日 はっきりみんな知らないんです
嘘だからね それだけの苦しみで人を救われる
菩薩はそんな桁違いますよ
キリスト教の方々にはね
糧がないんです 菩薩は受難を受けたことはもう10パラミットですからね
どれぐらい輪廻転生して数えられないですよ
あの数は 一応数字書いてますけどね
だからそういうのはね
どう受け取ればいいか私もわからないんです
まあ嘘っていうことは知ってますけどね
嘘ですけど 捨てられないんですね
なぜならば この教訓というものはあるんです
そこでこの他宗教と宗教同士で喧嘩しようと思っちゃうと
仏教はデータ持ってます
誰にも もう神秘であろうか
嘘であろうか これでもかい
これでもかいという膨大なデータは持っているんです
チベット仏教とクリスト教を合わせると
チベット仏教はもうオリンピックスプリンターみたいな力があって
それは小学生の程度の力だけ
クリスト教は だからあの神秘世界
並大抵なものじゃない
なんでそんなのあるのかとかね
えっと まあ思い出して喋ると時間すごくなくなりますからね
だって膨大な量を知ってますしね
はい 別なポイントを説明します
仏教にはこの神話っていうのは本当にもうどこで迷惑なんです
私はずっと仏教は科学やと言ってるでしょ
科学にはもう迷信って迷惑でしょ
今日土曜日だからこの実験するなよと
成り立たんでしょ 今日星々の組み合わせが良くないんだからね
この実験やめてくださいと
この患者さんに薬や注射を打つのをやめなさいと
というと 成り立たんでしょ
だから科学と迷信っていうのは全く別世界で
みずたむらと一緒にならないんです
だから仏教には神話 迷信っていうのはものすごい迷惑なんです
しかし これ神話 私は書きたい
神話の津波に仏教も当たって被害を受けたんだと
それで面白い いくつか言います
だから今日は全部思い出して喋らなくちゃかんだからね
あの アブッタダンマって言われる奇妙なというタイトルの教教があるんですよ
だからお経だから お釈迦様がおっしゃったような風にありますよ
それは菩薩には一般的なものだけでも
一般人には全く関係ない
ありえないことであると
全部リストは言えませんが
一個だけ言います お釈迦様が都市兜率天にいて
菩薩はね 人間のお母さんのお腹に入りますね
だからそこは神秘的な物語ですけど
実際お母さんが妊娠した話なんです
マーヤ夫人が妊娠しまったと
そちらには妊娠した生命体は兜率天から来たんだよと
菩薩は で まあそこまではまあいいや
しょうがない 妊娠した菩薩
がお腹の中に胎児でしょ
サッバンガパッチャンギアヒーネインドラ
すべて体ができてるんです
アヒーナインドラっていうのは何も欠けてないんだと
体に 我々知ってる胎児はもうすべて欠けてるでしょ
じわじわじわじわ部品ができてできて現れるでしょ
それをお釈迦様もそこら辺を教えていますよ
胎児はどうやって 成長するのは
最初はちょっとした肉だけやと
なんか別な名前使ってますけど
それからどんどん大きくなって
手足が出てきて 目耳鼻が出てきて
どんどん完全に体になったらドカンと外に出るんだと
菩薩は妊娠したらすぐもうサッバンガパッチャンギアヒーナっていうのは完全体の体なんですね
驚かない もっとあります
母親に自分の子供見えるんです
お腹の中で綺麗に結核させて座っているんですね
自分の子供が赤ちゃんが
それでみんなサードサードと信じています
私は聞きたいのは菩薩のお釈迦様にお釈迦様は十か月何でバカなことやってるんだよ
お腹の中で いらんでしょ？だって全部できてますから
生まれればいいのに 何であんなこと書くのかってよくわからん
それでも負けませんよ
仏教徒たちが イエスはまあなんかちょっと水を酒に変えただけでしょ
これ赤ちゃんが生まれて
それで体洗ってあげたら歩くんです
七歩 それでこれ奇妙なことだと
たとえ牛やら他の動物を馬やらね
生まれてすぐ歩くでしょ
そのように馬じゃないんだけど
菩薩は 生まれてすぐ歩くんです
やっぱりまだスパイス足らないんです
よりスパイス入れるんです
地面が開けて 蓮の花が出てくるんです
足を上げると花が現れてくる
次の足 また花が現れてきて
どうだと もっとこのドラマの刺激足らないともあります
フィナーレ 千賀何でしたっけ？千道千賀で言うが
どこが喋るんですよ また完璧な芸で
完璧なこの超エリートの文学作るできる人みたいにしっかりした言語でも喋ります
喋りますね それからどうしたんですかね
お釈迦様は 子供の頃は
面白くないね だって歩けるわ
喋るわ もう芸は唱えられるわ
もう それでストーリーが壊れちゃうでしょうに
だからそれなかったことにするんです
ストーリーはあまり嘘でもね
休み言わないと 休み休み休み休み言わないと
それでストーリーがつながらなくなっちゃって
突然結婚式から始まるんです
いや 教育から それから
あ 名名付ける祭りとかはね
必要なものは出てくるんだけどね
だからそういういらんですけど
あんなのは すべて歴史的に見られたいたら
インド人っていうのは
ブッダっていうのはいたっていうことも
外国から聞いた話なんです
そこまでインド人は知らなかったんです
それからあちこちからことをまとめて
こちらブッダがいた もうインチキ考古学的なものを作るんだけど
やっとアショーカは これはもう紀元前200あたりでしょうね
お釈迦様もっと古いでしょうに
歴史考古学的なものあるんだけど
面白いっていうのは 現代インド人のマハトマガンディーやら
そういうヒンドゥー教の超エリートの神秘主義者たちがね
ブッダっていう人がいたっていうことは
外国でライトオブアジアというさんが書いて書いて
あの本で知ったんです
あれ文学作品ですけど
なんだこりゃと ということは
お釈迦様があれほど地面を割って蓮の花まで上がるほどの奇跡を起こした人生であったならば
国民は忘れません そんなことは
だってそんなこと全くもないくせに
アメテラウオカミとかみんないまだに信じてるでしょうに
だからインド人すら忘れるほどの質素な生活をした方って言っちゃうと
やっぱり立場がないんですね
実際はそれなんですよ
みんなに目をかけないで自分で生活してるんだから
ほとんど隣の人一人知らないんです
そこでこの宗教テキストを作る人々は
狙いは仏教を破壊する狙いはないんで
当然 ブッダはいかに偉大なる人格者であるかと
二度と現れない人であるということは言いたいんだから
ああいう奇跡物語をつなげてつなげてつなげてつなげていくんです
だから私にこれって 例えば私が男性で出家比丘でしょ
この比丘はすごくいいですねとかね
まあ誰も思ってないんだけど
結構説法もするし 役にも立つし
だから尊敬しますと 私にこちらにピアス入れたり
頭に帽子かぶってかぶらせてあげたり
あのインド的な鼻にも穴を開けて何かダイヤでもぶら下げて
すごい迷惑でしょ ネックレスもつけてあげたり
首にショールもかけてあげたり
また何か武器を持ってきてね
これ金で あ これ手で取ってく
その方がかっこいいとかね
それで私は偉大な人になる
そんなことでしょう 釈迦様も被害者なんです
インドが しかし これデータを探している時でも
私はこの神秘的なデータ
いろんな会話が出てくるんですね
目に入るとびっくりするんですよ
あまりにも超インテリで
いかに人の理性に訴えて語っているのかと
だから それのいかにびっくりしたかということで
神話物語に持ってきちゃうと
全てパーになっちゃうんです
だから自分を例えて言えば
私はすごい力強く大胆に喋れますよと
何のことにも躊躇なく怖いものを知らす感じで
ものすごく喋りますよ
その人喋ると降ってる雨が止まりますよと
夏に雪が降りますよっていう神秘的な話を聞くとどうなる？すると沖縄の人々ははこちらでも説法してくださいと頼む
私は行く 沖縄の人々は
私は飛行機から降りると雪が降ってくるでしょう
周り見るでしょ そして雪が降ってこない
がっかりしますね それでがっかりするだけじゃなくて
私の話にも 集中はしないと
みんな雪が降るか降らないかと
沖縄の場合は雪が降った方が奇跡なんですね
そんなことをすごいお釈迦様は被害者ですね
インド文化の神秘さんのミステリー神秘主義は
で 非常に時間になりましたから
最近の一つ 面白い ポイントがあります
ジャイナ教のサッチャカというすごいエリートのバラモン人がいたんですね
その人はこのウェーサーリ国でエリート知識人で話し合ったりしていて
お釈迦様もそちらいるんだと話を聞いたんです
お釈迦様が色は無我である
受想行は無我であるだけという人だと
したら このサッチャカさんが笑っちゃって
え？変な人やと なんか頭おかしいやと
まともな人なら色受想行無我無我我にあらず言わんやと
お釈迦様は何か知識障害者やと思ったんですね
で 自慢するんですね じゃあ私は議論する
私はこの柱に 私と議論しなさいと言っちゃうと
柱さえ言う なんて言いますか
触れますよと それぐらい自分のこの議論する能力はすごいんです
だったら あんな間違ったくだらないアホな話言うんだったら
相手にもならんやと言って
とにかく議論するぞと
いくらなんでもこんな危険な教えはモッガラーナみたいな
あってはならんよと 世の中に
それでとにかく だから彼が自慢で言うんで
おっさなく 悪口言いたくなりますけどね
経典通りに言えば この山羊を山羊のひげがありますね
山羊をひげで取って あっち行って引っ張り
こっちに引っ張ったりすることは人間にできるような感じで
ひげで取っちゃうと山羊が弱くなっちゃうんですね
山羊には人間より力ある場合もありますけど
お釈迦様はこの屁理屈をお釈迦様に教えてくれるんだと言って来たんです
来たら議論を始めて お釈迦様に聞きますと
お釈迦様はどんな教えとまず来た
私はもう色は無我であり
受は受想行は無我であると教えていますよ
言ったら笑っちゃって笑ってね
私にたとえが思い出しますよと
最初のたとえを出したんですね
人間は大地の上にいて
大地で農作物をやって
大地の上で家を作って
大地の上で生活して 大地はないというと
どうなっているのかと
だから人間が生きることと大地っていうのは不可分でしょ
そんな哲学的な単語はないんだけど
経典ではね あんたの話はどんなもんなもんやと
言ったら お釈迦様 ああ
なるほど ではということは
あなた言うのはこの この物質的な物体がね
魂ってことでしょう？と言ったらそうでしょうと
物質なければ何もなりたらない
まあなるほど でも体が年取るね
あなた指令できますかね
体にこうなりなさい こうなりなさい
こうなってはならんやとかね
管理できるかと 体壊れてはならんとかね
答えてくださいと言った途端
自分の理論が負けたことがわかったんで
物質は勝手で人の魂じゃないんだと
それはもうお釈迦様 答えてくださいと
今 知識人の議論であると
知識人の議論の場合は
質問だったら答えなくちゃいけないと
そこは神秘的に持っていくんです
ブッダの質問に三回答えなかったら
頭が七つに割れますよと
あれが私ちょっと痛いんですね
だから嘘の真のもの あれ
サッチャの物語は正しいんです
すごい論理的な すごい科学的な
すごい理性的な対話なんです
そちらに注入するんです
神秘を 三回答えなかったら
あなたの頭がパチパチと割れちゃいますよと
だから神秘を作った人は勉強が足らなくて
私はヘーマラタナさんと言ったんで
私に聞けば 私は七種類に頭がイカれますで書きますよと
なぜならば この多重人格っていうのは普通の精神病気やと
これは七重になったっても大したことないんだと
七キャラを持ったってもね
私ならそう書きますよと
まあもともといらんだけどね
どうしてもゴミ収入するならば
そこで本人が負けたんだから
痛い 有名な人でしょ ドロドロ汗が出て
だからでっかいターバンあった
ターバン濡れちゃって
汗が落ちるんですよ 床に
お釈迦様はなんのことなく
あのね あなたこんな自慢したでしょ？私は柱にこう総論かけても柱させ揺れますよと
人間のことはもう言うまでもないんだと
それで私はこの地面濡れてるでしょ？今はあなたの汗で
ほら 見て 私の体 自分の体見せるんで汗一滴もない
そこで答えてくださいと言っちゃうと
頭がおかしくなっちゃったんだ
お釈迦様 もう一度教えてくださいと言ってお釈迦様の答えはい
わかりましたという 私は物質は無我であるということはわかりました
ってことで 負けて負けていくんで
負ける その時はワジラパーニという鬼が来て
ワジラという真言密教で変なもの使ってるでしょ？あれ
あれ原子爆弾です あれで地球にやっちゃうと
地球が全部破壊して燃えて
だいたいまあ百年 百年ぐらい何も植物何も植えなくなりますよ
素晴らしい武器です で
ワジラを持ってきて お前ブッダの質問に答えなかったら
あなたの頭を七つに割れてやるぞと
それワッジラ持ってくる必要ないでしょうね
人間の頭だからそんなに硬くないんです
だからそこでストーリー
ゴミ入れた人も あ これちょっとまずいと思ったみたいです
それでこう書くんです
しかし このワジラパーニという
今菩薩もいます ワジラパーニという
新しいキャラが変わって
の姿がブッダとサッチャカに見える
他の人には見えませんよと
それで一応シートベルトもつけちゃうんです
くだらなくて あの話は
だからあれほど論理的に読んでもびっくりする
あのエピソード あの議論の記録を
こんなものを入れちゃって
本人がこれですごいかっこよくだろうと思ったんだけどね
これ男にネックレスつけたような感じなんです
かっこ悪くなるんです
で まあそういう風にいろいろ問題っていうのは仏教の世界にもあります
だから結論なんですけど
嘘を言うなよっていうのは仏教なんですけど
こんなものを言ったらどうなるのかと
だからそれでハンディは嘘を言わない文化の宗教だから
一般信者さんたちが まあ昔の人々が書いたものだから
事実に違いありませんと信仰するんです
嘘を言うわけないやと
これ一つの問題なんです
坊主であってもとんでもない嘘を言うやって言っちゃうと
坊主の立場がなくなるし
勉強していない この神話と人間の関係っていうものは
神話は嘘が我々のエモーショナル的に感情的に神話が好きという
だから神話がなく なかなか成り立たないっていうね
だから食べ物の場合でも
何か食べればいいのに
我々は美しく切って 皿の上に何か形よく並べて置くでしょうに
そうだから ちゃんと皿で美しく盛ったら栄養分上がる？上がらないんです
でも 新聞の上で出すよりは皿の上に出した方がいいということになる
そういう関係なんですね
それでお釈迦様がこれはすごく問題だと
人間に真理を真偽の区別できないのはどういうわけ？神秘主義だから
だから仏教の世界で お釈迦様は 10ヶ月間菩薩がお腹の中で何やったのかと
時間もったいないという辛口言えるのはスマナサーラだけなんです
無駄でした あの10日間と 10ヶ月間は
だって体出来ていたんだから
ですから この真偽の差をわからない限り
あれのものは事実わからないでしょ
無我であるとわからないでしょ
自我って幻覚だとわからないでしょ
だって幻覚でいるんだから
この人々はなんとか都合信じているんだから
希望叶ってくれる だからお釈迦様は煩悩のリストに束縛のリストに入れていたんです
回向 回向衆 シーラッブタ・パラマーサ
でお釈迦様ってやっぱりこの神話物語
神々の物語っていうのは
それはそんなに危険性がないんだからね
子どもたちでも楽しく読んでるんだから
このいわゆるエデュケーショナルバリューという教育価値あるものはには批判してないんです
スピリチュアル価値あるもの
すべて 例えば聖地の山があるとかね
聖地の聖地と言わない
聖なる川があるとかね
聖なる山があるとかね
その山に登ったら もうシヴァ神が直々あなたに頭に何か入れるとか
それ入れてもらうためには
3ヶ月間断食してそっちで待たなくちゃいかんとか
とにかく実行不可能な修行を設定するんです
シヴァ神が素晴らしいやと
シヴァ神が出てきば修行するならばと
どんな仕事行ったらなかなか実行不可能
例えばヒマラヤみたいな
そこら辺とか山に隠れて
まあ最低 5  6  7年ぐらい裸足裸で瞑想します
死にますよ  1日で だからボートセーフ
こちらもあちらもセーフ
だって試せないんだから
だからそうやって人類永久的に自分自身で自分を馬鹿にしているでしょうに
それ破った人は預流果なんです
だから苦行はないんです
仏教ではこういう変な儀式儀礼もないんです
お数かせません お数を持つならば
ヒッパな坊主はなんだらかんからの場所にあるなんだらかんだらの木の種で
なんだらかんだらの人に頼んで作ってもらわなきゃダメやとか
だからキリスト教もインドからね
お数珠の習慣をパクっちゃったんだけど
あるいはローマ教皇から直々もらったロータリーには力があるとかね
そのローゼ 人の顔の前でこうやってぶら下がっちゃうと
直ちに病気が治るとかね
だから宗教は人の病気が治るは
奇跡が起こすは でもデータゼロ
それは面白い データゼロですけど
信じてはいるんです 日本でもハンドパワーで癌は治すは
しかし 日本の死ぬ人々の数は癌で一番多いでしょ
しかし 宗教はいつだって健在
何なの？と だから これ人間の知識ハンディなんです
お釈迦様はあれほど頑張ったんだけど
なかなかこのハンディキャップインテリジェンスということをね
なくすことはなかなかうまくいかないんですね
だから この別な道 自ら確かめなさいというこのところで
この預流果に達したら
もう一切迷信ないんです
綺麗に心が清らかになるんです
だからお釈迦様 この人だけ揺らがない仏法僧の信頼があるんだと
だから信仰ではない それは信仰するために嘘でなければ成り立たない
神を信じる 阿弥陀さんを信じる
観音を信じる ブッダを信じる
その場合は嘘でないと
子供は私はお母さんを信じると言った場合も
嘘のことを信じています
いわゆるお母さんならこうこうやってくれるだろうと妄想して信じるんです
だから信じるという言葉を入れた時点で
ちょっと信頼性がないということになるんです
それが嘘であればあるほど
強く信じなくちゃあかんのです
では なんで信仰はそこまであるのかというと
これ脳のカラクリで プラシーボで病気が治ります
だからそういう問題 ね
そういうわけであの痛い痛いのは飛んでいけというところでは飛んでいきませんと預流果の人は知っています
預流果に達していない人たちは
みんな痛い痛いのは飛んでいけと言ったら
ああ なるほど 信じますという立場でいるんです
だからミスティシズムアンドリリジアンというのは切り離せない関係なんです
だから すべての宗教は嘘の上で成り立っているんです
嘘を抜けちゃうと宗教は壊れてしまいます
宗教は微妙にかすかに道徳的なことを言うんだから
なんかなくては困るという風にみんな思っているのですが
宗教は貢献するものよりは社会に迷惑をかけるの方がかなり大きいんです
ブッダの教えは宗教ではないんだけど
やっぱりインド文化で現れたんだから
仏教は誰にも負けないぐらい神秘物語を大量に持っているんです
だから それにやられると
仏教の人々の修行がうまくいかなくなっちゃう場合もあります
そういうことで すべての迷信を破って
ありのままの事実を発見することはお釈迦様がおっしゃっている最初の悟り
預流果になります 話は以上です
ありがとうございます
はい あとちょっと私の方からちょっとお聞きしたいんですけど
2つあるんですけど あの
例えばその仏典の中でも在家の方が先祖供養で回向をした場合に
どのように届くのかという質問をした経典がありまして
それでその話を聞いた方がですね
最終的に私はその供養の結果があるということは確かめられないけれど
お釈迦様の今お話しされたことを私は信じますというふうに言って終わる経典が確かあったんですね
アングッターニカイヤ
その場合 まああの確かめられないけど
お釈迦様の言うことを信じますという場合は
これは神秘主義とは言えないのかなという感じもちょっとしたんですけど
そんな場所私は思い出しませんだけどね
先祖供養の場合は お釈迦様に私が知っている場所は
その人は先祖供養を信じている人で
文化的に だから面倒くさいんだけど
やらなくちゃいけない
日本のお盆みたいなお盆でしょ
だから先祖供養 結果があるのかと
うるさいこれはという気持ちで質問したんで
だからこんなのは要りませんと言ったら
よかったよかった 今日から先祖供養やめるということに結果になるんだから
その人はもともとやりたくなかったんです
ジャーヌ総理 彼の名前はね
だからこの だから私はお釈迦様は分析的に答えていたんです
お釈迦様は自分自身先祖供養しなさいと推薦するということは
そういう経典には私は思い出しませんよ
シンハー将軍と対話した話だったと思うんですけど
アンヌターニカイヤの結構後ろの方だったと思うんですけど
だから別所のめくるの経典でしょ
それは  要するに先祖供養をして
それがちゃんと届くのかどうかと
それで直接のそれで まあなんとかという学びに生まれ変わってた場合は
先祖が届きますけど それ以外の場合は誰かに届くでしょうというふうにお釈迦様がおっしゃって
で その話を私は信じますと
だから その話の元々 あのジャーヌ総理に言った言葉なんですね
だからそれはまた繰り返しちゃったでしょうね
だからちょっと場違いということもありえますよ
お釈迦様の言葉だから信じますというのは
預流果の人々だけなんですね
けど まあまあ別にお釈迦様が今までおっしゃったことには何の問題もないんだからね
例えば私もよく出会う問題は輪廻転生はあるのかいと
お釈迦の教えはあれほど科学的で
あれほど精密で あれほど完璧ですから
そちらに物事は転生するんだいということだけ間違っているというふうには言いづらいんですね
だから言って 私に確かめられるか
確かめられないんです
科学実験をやりたいんだけど
これはちょっと管轄外なんですね
だから科学的に もう例えば宇宙に行って何かするとかね
理論だけなんですね 宇宙空間でこうこうしましょうとかね
理論だけで実際はできないんです
例えば月の裏側の写真をほとんど見たことがない
私は簡単に撮れるでしょ？衛星一つ飛ばしちゃって
なんか覚えてないんです
月はずっと地球を同じ顔を見えてるんだから
裏側の写真も見たいんです
まあとにかく だからこの
実験 現実的に不可能なっていうところもある
だから輪廻転生はそんなもので
ちょっと難しいんですね
なぜならば この人々は実験するための前提を作る場合は間違いを起こすんです
私が生まれ変わるのか
そこを前提間違ってるんですよ
だから実験しても進めない
答えが出てこない それで私がっていうのは妄想概念だとまっすぐ入らなくちゃあかんです
そうすると その人は実験しません
だって私がなかったら物は流れるのは当たり前の事実でしょうに
この一つだけこれも流れると聞く必要ないでしょ
例えば 水がずっと地球回転してるでしょ
それを知った人はガラスいっぱい水を持って
この水が回転するでしょうね
実験してやると するやる必要はないんです
水だよ ある程度 これは飲もうか
料理に使おうか 植木鉢に入れようが回転するんです
ですから 私がいないということを発見していたら
当然 輪廻転生の科学的な事実であるということに行かないんです
だけど とにかく現代人
人間にとってはそこはちょっとアクセスできないレベルなんです
だからそれは別な次元の話ではっきり言ってるでしょう
だからについては まあお釈迦様もおっしゃってることだから
だからそこで  信じておきますと
おっしゃったお釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
まあ信じてもいいんじゃない？ということになる
危険じゃないでしょ 信じた方が信じないよりはいいんです
同じこと 洗濯用届かない
わからんだけど 洗濯をした方がしないよりはマシです
だって洗濯用する習慣があると
自分にも同じ運命あるんだとわかるでしょうに
だから善行為するべきというところに行くでしょう
だからそこで道徳的な価値がありますけど
科学的に証拠を出して確かめたいというと
これはちょっと あの ずっと人間にはアクセスできないところになるんですね
はい あともう一つなんですけど
先ほどのサッチャが教の話なんですけど
確かにその如来から三度問われたことに
三度理由のある問いを問われて
それにちゃんと回答しなかったら
頭が七つに裂けますよというふうにお釈迦様はおっしゃったんですよね
これって私がちょっと思ったのは
サッチャさんがそもそも持っている
そういう迷信というか
そういう知識人に関するインド人の信仰みたいなものを持ち出して
それを言ったんじゃないかなって感じもしたんです
というのは もう一つ どこかで私は確か中部経典だと思うんですけど
心の力っていうことをお釈迦様が強調するときに
仙人を 侮辱したことによって街が丸ごと消えてしまったみたいな
そういう伝説があるでしょっていうことを持ち出して
心の力っていうのを説得したっていうフレームがどっかであったんですね
それと同じように 相手が持っている信仰を使って説得するっていうのを
お釈迦様は時々やるので
それを言ったんじゃないかなって感じもちょっとしたんですけど
そういう説もできます
だからジャイナ教ではそんな話あるかどうかわからないしね
あの仙人の力で街が燃えしまったっていうことは
ヒンドゥー教の一般 まあだって猿も神様だからね
まあ別に大したことはないんですけどね
だから相手の武器で相手を倒すというね
やり方でね それには自分たちが信じる必要はないんですね
しかし このサッチャンの場合は
ものすごい知識人同士の対話でしたからね
だからサッチャの自慢というのは
あれはただの PR で 俺はなかなか怖いぞと言った程度のものなんです
ああいう風に大げさに言うのはあまり構いません
インドではよく大げさに言うんですね
だから そこをもってサッチャをちょっと貶すのも仕方がないんだけどね
頭が割れることはちょっと問題であって
それも放っておきましょう
ワジラパーニなんて来たんです
それはちょっと書き加えたのかなって感じもしますね
そこでそうやって書き加えたんだけど
大丈夫けど大事なキャラなんです
結局はワジラパーニ菩薩なんです
それで密教ではもうものすごい大事な道具なんです
あれはなんて言います？金剛
金剛ですね  スリランカに今頭から総理大臣もいつでもこれ持ってあれば
それも回しちゃうと自分の国民がみんな騙しちゃって
自分を王様に見てもらう
崇め崇めてくれると思ってるんです
だからスリランカの総理大臣はヒンドゥー教だからね
どんな宗教でも金に金になるならば
どんな宗教も信じるんです
だからずっと金剛金で作ってね
だって自分のお金じゃないんだからね
結構大きいのに そこでいつでもこうやって回してるんですよ
はい ありがとうございました
では いろいろ質問いただいてますけど
木曜日の日に  はい 質問に木曜日答えます
では終了いたします ケーナン プラーナンナワンナティサンバワンウィラッタチッターイティケーパーメンテーケーナヴィージャイルリッチャンダーニッバンティテ
ィーラーヤターヤンパティーポーイダンビサンケーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナサッチャーユトゥエーテーナサッチャワッチャーナドッカーブーパサメ
ントゥテーエーテーナサッチャワッチャーナバーラーブーパサメントゥテーエーテーナサッチャワッチャーナローカーブーパサメントゥテー
はい ありがとうございます
カンティー パラマントポーティ ティンカー ニッバーナ パラマム ワダンティー ブッダ